people will see that as failure and
they'll be like why even do that why put
yourself through that me on the other
hand like I don't see life the same way
they do so I see it as like that was
awesome dude like us three we created
like this thing everyone got shirts it
was like awesome and we didn't lose
money and we learned so much from it
yeah and maybe there's got to tell
myself that so I don't feel bad about it
but at the same time I truly do believe
that and I feel like good about it yeah
it's it's entrepreneurship and happen
your destiny in your own hand is it's
not for everybody and I'm not saying
that it's better or worse I'm saying
just some people just aren't built for
it why it's like is it for you or not
that's all I'm saying cuz I if I'm just
being completely honest I would like to
be able to have that mentality where I
could there are some people who are so
good at doing the same thing every day
and they live in [ __ ] bliss and
that's the kind of life that I sometimes
Envy because if you like routine if you
like women I wish I would really like
routine cuz if I did then I wouldn't
have to waste my time trying to figure
out everything every day it's kind of
it's like I look at them like I have a
friend guys an engineer and the guy just
he's very happy working his nine-to-five
and been doing his hobbies on the
weekend yeah I want to do my hobbies
24/7 yeah in here say me I want to do my
hobbies 24/7 yeah for sure and that's
the hard part right it's like okay well
if you're going to be in that realm then
you got to figure out how to make these
hobbies profitable mm-hmm and live like
that even when it fails you gotta take
those losses and move on Ram it and try
again try and try again and that's gonna
be what you're gonna be doing for the
rest of your life yeah I mean money's
always good but I got into this because
of the lifestyle yeah like it's like I
gotta get creative on how to maintain
this lifestyle so I could make this work
talking to my friend and work this is
work this is worth talking to my friend
and entertaining people sharing my
thoughts like how can I make food like
work yeah you only mean like in some
people get into business for different
reasons they'll be like yeah just want
to make a [ __ ] ton of money I just want
to figure out things some people get in
for more like a holistic reason or like
a more community reason like I want to
change the world I want to help people
there's so many different reasons why
people get into business
but I always say like there's two things
people should all do is one do a start a
business I want everyone in the world to
just start a business and try it yeah
and and just experience it even if they
don't stick with it just to know what
it's like and to is serve people like
you and a restaurant yeah
humbly I want I want people everyone to
experience what it's like to be a server
at a restaurant yeah that [ __ ] will
change you man it's it's and don't even
look at it I say don't even look at like
what we do to as something people should
be envious of just know that we found
our lane and figure out what your lane
is yeah you know because a lot of the
times I hear people say this they go I
could do that too
alright [ __ ] do it then if you could do
what we do what a [ __ ] arrogant [ __ ]
yeah you hear that [ __ ] all the time it
was like I could do that
mmm Madhu be my [ __ ] guest those are
like the guys at the UFC fights that are
watching him oh you don't know what
you're doing it's like really dude like
ya go in the [ __ ] cage yeah like you
you be my [ __ ] guest even people who
do podcast right but I could do a
podcast you really [ __ ] cut it though
yeah and the reason why is just you're
just weren't built for it do you think
it's easy sitting here having commerce
it's like it's easy for us because it's
natural and we've done so much stupid
[ __ ] in our lives and [ __ ] up so many
times we have so many things to talk
about it's a skill though it's just it's
a skill to have you don't think that
I've brought like three or four people
here already to sit at this table and
have this conversation and they could
not do it yeah they couldn't do it and I
didn't understand why and it's just
because some people aren't wired like
that no they didn't just didn't didn't
build a skill set yeah cuz I look at my
best friend he's a physician he's in his
last year of his residency and I I would
never say to him I could do what you do
I could [ __ ] cut out a heart and put
a new one in yeah even dude even
somebody like this dude named James cage
white I love that is his Asian dude that
goes up he puts his feelings and his
hearts on the line every day yeah Hey
Dude Tim just sent me a text to the
school he posted Twitter post
it's a photo that he set up so he put
you could tell he posted his phone on a
coffee cup and
he set the timer up and he sits there
and he grabs his head like this and you
were crying pretending to cry yes and
say oh how come I came out finding love
you saw I can't do that I cannot be him
if I was him I'd die I would [ __ ] die
that's genius that's genius word you
gotta love that [ __ ] yeah I respect his
hustle I could not draw those
three-year-old drawings and ask people
if it's a good drawing and put it on a
t-shirt and sell it as merch I'm not
with this [ __ ] but that [ __ ] and
I'm gonna buy another one soon yo shout
out the james cage white yo if you're
ever in the states you are allowed to
come on genius brain pod can tell ya I
want to pick your sad brain I mean I
need him here dude I [ __ ] I've
thought about it because the Tim in this
dude yeah and because I already know how
similar our sense of humor is I already
knew I was gonna love this guy I was on
vine cuz he started up he was on mine
yeah he was on vine I was on that
[ __ ] vine 30 minute vine compilation'
I watched it like 20 times my various
way I liked it I liked so the backstory
to this guy is this guy James Cage white
he's in China and he was trying to learn
how to speak English
yeah through vine right who's practicing
English through vine so he would put it
up and he would get feedback on it so he
was just practicing talking to somebody
which is actually a great way to learn
how to speak English yeah and it just
blew up into something else because he's
so innocent yeah he doesn't know how
ridiculous yeah I like a bow oh I got so
[ __ ] mad when he when he started
saying banana right banana he used to
say but ladder but I'll already good hey
he's our Polara very cool very swag I
like it and then some people were
cracking jokes oh I'm saying yo you call
a banana that he never says banana
anymore oh don't break the [ __ ] joke
dude let him say pie ladder bar ladder
these are Burrell and her I [ __ ] love
that guy dude
alright I remember his like food that he
would always post it what I loved about
the dude is he's so [ __ ] grateful oh
yeah like he he's eating like garbage
slop like straight-up factory peasant
[ __ ] and then he's like beef he's very
delicious I like it and I was like it's
literally just like rice
in water with a little bit of pickles on
the side and I was like what the [ __ ]
dude this guy is so sick and then he's
eating a banana or like a Apple like
it's the it's like as a dessert dude and
then you would give him $25 for his tea
she would which in China is like [ __ ]
like 60 bucks in a heartbeat I would do
it so he could have bananas for life did
I I genuinely liked that guy man there
are some people on the internet that are
so innocent [ __ ]